what's up everybody we got our first
official trailer for Shazam and it looks
amazing honestly after seeing this I'm
kind of starting to think that DC will
in fact make a comeback this is an
origin story and I think that the
trailer shows it very well unfortunately
I don't have the rights to show the full
trailer so if you want to see it check
out the link in the description below
and come back here for the full
breakdown so let's dissect so just like
in the comics and the movie Billy Batson
is an orphan and he's a rather Abellio
sore Fionn the trailer states that he's
ran away from foster homes in six
counties he clearly wants to be on his
own but since he's not 18 he has to be
taken in by a foster family and that's
what we see here and that's where he
meets his buddy Freddy Freeman who is a
superhero buff and did you happen to
catch those Batman and Superman Easter
eggs we then cut to a scene where Freddy
is asking Billy what kind of superpowers
he would like to have if he was a
superhero Freddy then comes to his
rescue and then tries to outrun the guys
that he just beat up and then he gets on
board a subway this is where he hears
the words of the wizard who says he's
chosen him as his champion he then gets
off at the Wizards lair
he then meets the wizard and the wizard
tells him to say his name so his powers
can flow through him he finds out his
name is Shazam and once he says Shazam
himself he turns into Shazam so far this
is actually pretty comic-book accurate
this is exactly how he gets his powers
from the comics and for those of you who
aren't familiar yes he is this kid and
even when he turns into Shazam
he still is fourteen-year-old Billy
Batson and that's sort of where the
comedy is going to come into play with
this character and this movie you have
this huge super powerful superhero with
a 14 year old controlling the body so
naturally as a 14 year old kid he freaks
out that he just became a superhero and
he runs home to get Freddy and tell him
about what happened him and Freddy
obviously start to freak out cuz they're
both little kids and then Freddy being
the superhero buff asked him what powers
he has so he has no idea seeing as he
just turned into a superhero so the next
scene that we see is him
determining what powers he has I think
these scenes and really just the overall
tone of the trailer shows just how funny
this movie is going to be and
light-hearted and just kind of really
different than all the other DC movies
that we've seen so in this trailer we
find out that he has superhuman strength
he can almost fly he can harness
electricity and he's bulletproof were
also introduced to dr. sivana in the
comics dr. sivana is Shazam's main arch
enemy and is a mad scientist once upon a
time in the comics he actually goes to
Venus and becomes really popular and
then he comes back to earth so I'm
curious to what his backstory will be in
the movie they don't really give him
much screen time in this trailer and
they kind of just make it about the
origin of Shazam which I'm perfectly
fine with I think it was awesome but
again I am really curious to see how
he's gonna fight against Shazam in the
movie we get a really cool clip of Billy
Batson walking to something it's
probably dr. sivana
and he says Shazam and lightning strikes
from the sky and boom he turns into him
and I think it looks really awesome I
think the transformation of how Billy
turns into Shazam by saying his name is
really well done I was kind of worried
about it but after seeing this trailer I
actually am really really excited to see
this movie it looks funny and
light-hearted like they said it would be
but at the same time it does seem like
it's going to have a lot of action to it
and I don't think it's too cheesy
that was actually one of the things that
I was worried about is that it was just
gonna be too cheesy but seeing him
actually say the word Shazam and turn
into him I'm on board and then of course
the final scene is of him and Freddie
talking to a girl and I think it's
hilarious because he still is this
fourteen-year-old kid but now he's stuck
in this adult muscular body who is a
superhero and can talk to girls and the
way he does it is just awesome
hey what's up I'm a superhero classic so
there you have it breakdown of the first
trailer that we've seen for Shazam I'm
super pumped to see it it looks like
it's going to be really good but let me
know what you all think in the comments
below hit that like button and subscribe
to my channel so you can stay up-to-date
on Shazam DC Marvel and all things
superhero
thank you so much for watching woof woof
[Music]